سلسله من الجدل شهدتها منظومه التعليم في
مصر ومحورها الدروس الخصوصيه التي تشكل
ظاهره توصف بالسلبيه وزاره التربيه
والتعليم بصدد التقدم بمشروع قانون مجلس
النواب خاص باصدار رخصه مزاوله مهنه
المعلم حسب المصادر بدون هذه الرخصه لن
يتمكن اي خريجه من المشاركه في التعليم
باي شكل من الاشكال سواء في مدرسه خاصه او
مركز تعليميه وسيتم معاقبه المخالفين
بتهمه امتحان صفات معلم هذا الاجراءات بعد
انتقادات واسعه لتصريحات وزير التربيه
والتعليم
عن نيته ترخيص مراكز الدروس الخصوصيه لهذا
في جعلها بيئه امنه الدوله حقها من ضرائب
عائدات الدروس الخصوصيه والتي تبلغ سبعه
47 مليار جنيه
الوزير دافع عن نفسه قائلا انها فكره
وليست قرار ليطالب بتجريمها واغلاقها 70%
منها مزيد عن هذه الظاهره معك على
رخصه مزاوله مهنه التعليم في مصر مشروع
قانون سيقدم لمجلس النواب المصري يهدف
لتطوير ملف التعليم ومواجهه الدروس
الخصوصيه التي تشكل ازمه النميقه تواجه
كثيرا من البيوت المصريه الوزاره هي التي
ستمنح رخصه مزاوله مهنه معلم بعد عدد من
الاختبارات يخضع لها المتقدم للحصول عليها
في مصر وعلى مدار سنوات
تكافح الحكومه مراكز الدروس الخصوصيه
الممنوعه اصلا بموجب القانون لكنها اصبحت
ظاهره ومنظومه تعليميه موازيه تشكل هناك
مقارا للعشرات من التلاميذ في فصول مزدحمه
وتمتد لتشمل طلاب المرحله الابتدائيه حتى
ويطلقوا المدرسون الذين يديرون هذه
المراكز اسماء على انفسهم مثل مايسترو
الالماني فارس الكيمياء رئيس جمهوريه
اللغه العربيه
افلاطون الفلسفه وملك الحساب وغيرها من
الاسماء وزير الا التربيه والتعليم المصري
الذي اعتبر تصريحاته حول تقنين سناتر
التعليم فهمت بشكل خاطئ تحدث عن انفاق
اكثر من 47 مليار جنيه على الدروس
الخصوصيه بينما تقرير الجهاز المركزي
للتعبئه والاحصاء يكشف عن انفاق الاسره
المصريه اكثر من 100 و36 مليار جنيه سنويا
لما تقتصر اقتراحات الوزير على مراكز
الدروس وانما امتدت لتشمل مجموعات التقويه
التي تنظمها المدارس الحكوميه كاداه
لمكافحه الدروس الخصوصيه واعتبر ان هذه
المجموعات غير فعاله معلنا اسنادها لشركه
خاصه لادارتها
سالنا الناس في مصر كيف يمكن معالجه مشكله
ظاهره الدروس الخصوصيه او السناتر وهل
يمكن ان يساعد فرض رخصه معلم لحل هذه
المشكله
[موسيقى]
كده كده سواء حبه يمنعه سناتر سواء حبه من
الدروس الخصوصيه هتتعمل هتتعمل وهيدوا
هيدوا سواء في البيوت سواء في السنافر ده
هيتم هيتم كل الدنيا بتستفاد دلوقتي من
السنتر الشباب وبنات واطفال صغيرين
بيتعلموا كثير جدا القصه دي مشترك فيها
اثنين المدرسيه
التلميذ عشان التلميذ بليد وما بيذاكر
حياته كلها بقت النت
والسوشيال ميديا والحاجات ديت لكن
طبيعي
ان المدرسه تقوم بدورها محتاجين ان احنا
نزود اعداد المدارس العيال
انت هتسيطر عليها ازاي
ما هو لازم يعني ينواجه وبعدين بصراحه
عشان نبقى متفقين الناس اللي بتمسك
الوزارات او الهيئات بكافه وبيحاولوا
هي عاوزه حاجه
قانون اسمه قانون الضمير
[موسيقى]
على كل من القهر ينضم الينا الصحفي ورئيس
قسم التعليم في بوابه الاهرام احمد حافظ
احمد يسعد صباحك اول المعلومات اوفر حول
هذا المقترح حول منح رخصه لمزاوله
هو مقترح مشروع القانون
بيستهدف حوالي 70% من
المعلمين العاملين في سيناء الدروس
الخصوصيه
هنتكلم على 70% من الخريجين اللي عاملين
في مراكز الدروس الخصوصيه بدون رخصه
مزاوله مانع يعني هم مش معلمين يعني
الخريج
لا
لا احصاء رسمي وزاره التربيه والتعليم ان
70% من العاملين في مراكز الدروس الخصوصيه
مش معلمين ولم يحصلوا على رخصه مزاوله
مهنه ال 30% الباقيين انا بتكلم عن دول
اللي هم شغالين في المدارس الحكوميه
مقترح مشروع القانون بيتكلم عن المعلم
اللي شغال في سنتر تعليمي واللي شغال في
مدرسه خاصه همم معظم المعلمين اللي شغالين
في مدارس خاصه في مصر
من التربيه والتعليم يعني دي المدرسه
بتجيبهم من همم الكليه
خلاص بيشتغل معها في المدرسه
لو نجح فيها بياخذ رخصه مزوره منها خلاص
ما نجحش فيها خلاص ولازم يكون منضم لنقابه
المعلمين جميع العاملين في السنافر الدروس
الخصوصيه غير منضمين لنقابه المعلمين
هيكون من شروط الحصول على الرخصه انك تكون
عضو في نقابه المعلمين وانك ما عليكش اي
معوقات امنيه ولا جنائيه تفضلي
مراكز تعليميه دروس خصوصيه شو المشكله
بالاساس
المشكله الاساسيه ان احنا عندنا نقص حد
جدا في المعلمين في المدارس احنا بنتكلم
عندنا 26 مليون طالت المدارس الحكوميه لهم
980,000 معلم فقط كانوا مليون ونصف معلم
ولكن الباقي ده كله خرج على المعاش احنا
بنتكلم عندنا في مصر من 40 ل 50,000 معلم
بيخرجوا على المعاش الثانويه
يعني الحكومه قررت تعيين 150,000 معلم على
خمس سنوات يعني معدل 30,000 معلم كل سنه
ولكن للاسف اللي بيخرجوا على المعاش سنويا
هم اللي بيدخلوا يعني هيتعينه لكن يعني
المشكله الاساسيه مصر تعاني من عجز في
المعلمين يصل الى 325,000 معلم
يضاف اليه من اللي بيخرجوا من المعاش
سنويا 30 40,000 معلم يعني التعيينات
المعلمين في مصر لم تعالج المشكله
الاساسيه اللي هي عندنا نقص حد جدا في
المعلمين فمعظم الطلبه بتروح المدرسه مش
بتلاقي معلم والوزاره امام شحن موارد
ولازم الاقتصاديه قررت الاستعانه بمعلمين
بالحصه او معلمين متطوعين مجانا وده لا
يمكن يعالج الازمه
عجز في المعلبين والعدس في النظام
التعليمي قبل مناقشه الدروس خصوصيه التي
الطلاب هم بحاجه اليه اليوم
ما هو ده السبب اللي خلى اولياء الامور
متحفظين جدا ضد ان احنا هنعمل شرعانا
للضروسيه في مصر لان ده كده الحكومه بترفع
ايديها عن التعليم الحكومي في مصر طبعا
امام غضب المعلمين تم تجديد تم تجميد
المخترع يعني يمكن معلومه لحضرتك تم تجميد
مقترح تقنين الدروس الخصوصيه واعتقد ان
البديل هو رخصه مزاوله مهنه لان الوزاره
ما تعرفش مين واقف في السنتر بيشرحه او
ولي الامر نفسه ما يعرفش مين واقف في سنتر
بيشرح هل هو معلم معترف بيه من الوزاره
ولا المعلم متطفل ولا بخيل على المهنه
عشان كده الوزاره قررت تعمل من نقطه وزاره
مهنه هتطبعها على المعلمين على الاقل اللي
هم دول مهنه يخرجوا من السماء
نحن نشكرك جزيل الشكر من القاهره الصحفي
ورئيس قسم التعليم في بوابه الاهرام احمد
حافظ شكرا لك